MIKE MATHESON IS BACK FOR
PENGUINS HE HAS BEEN BACK WITH A
KED ABOUT, HE IS
PRETTY GOOD IN THAT DEPARTMENT.
>> THIS IS
HIS SHOT.
IT BOUNCES OFF THE AND WELL, IT
IS CARLSON, OVERTAKEN, OUTCOME
THAT PENGUINS ON GO AT
TIMESTHE
ICE, HE IS ONE OF THE GUYS THAT
CAN GET IT IN SHORTHANDED.
>> Dan: SMITH BY WHITE CLOUD EH
CROSBY,  LETANG,  LEFT OVER TO
MALKIN .
WE HAVE STATES CORLISS.
>> Bob: GREAT PRESSURE BY THE
A
OTHER HEALTHY SCRATCH. HERE IS
STOPPED BY  BROSSOIT.
AND THAT IS IN.ABLE TO GET HIM
INTO THE NET
>> Dan: TOSSED IN THE CENTER
BEEN FOLLOWING UP WHO WAS RIBUT
WE MENTIONED MOVING THE PUCK ON
THE BACKHAND, MIKE MATHESON IS
BACK IN THE LINEUP,
PIETRANGELO COMES LATE, TAKES
WATCH THE WOMEN'S GAME.
IF THEY CHOOSE THAT THE ROLE
MODEL WILLRE --
>> Dan: HE HAD IT, BUT LOSOS
>> Bob: THERE E ,
ANOTHER WIN FOR THE CANADIANS,
THE FIFTH OF THE OLYMPIC
COMPETITION.WITH BACKHAND, SHUT
BOYLE, HIT IT OFF.
THAT ALLOWED FRIEDMAN TO JOIN
THE RUSH,
EICHEL  BACK TO THEODORE.
>> Bob: THE OFFICIAL MAY ALSO
HAVE BLOWN THE WHISTLE E
REFLECTED INTO THE CORNER
CROSBY, GOING UP AGAINST RUST.
, IT CAME ACROSS. YOU
JUST GOT